bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale championnat du monde de féminin
2016 entre donc mariam ou zouk
la tenante du titre et iphone ou qui
était la précédente tenant du titre qui
en fait n'a pas vraiment perdu donc son
championnat je vous le rappelle ce match
était prévu après que donc mariés vous
étudiez gagné le tournoi de l'an dernier
qu'on avait suivi mais oui fans
n'étaient pas présentes
voilà donc ce match constitue très
certainement le véritable championnat du
monde entre donc l'ukrainienne et la
chinoise la chinoise qui donc mène d'un
point après les deux premières parties
et ce démarrage fait craindre le pire
pour la suite du match puisque maria
musi tout n'a rien montré dans la
première avec les blancs et s'est fait
contrer et a dû concéder le nul assez
rapidement et par contre c'est fait
vraiment débordé complètement dans la
deuxième alors donc là ici de nouveaux
marjanovic août à l'eiblen qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire comment va-t-elle
réagir face à l'ifan ou la chinoise
on y va c'est parti avec et bien des cas
déjà une surprise voilà puisque on va
rien par rapport à la première
vous l'avez essayé eu 4 est donc là elle
change tout de suite ce sens répertoire
cavaliers 6 c4 donc ça c'est normal
coûts de développement normaux e.cisse
voilà donc c'est déjà un premier
premières indications a priori on va
sortir donc le fou du côté ouest ouest
n'diaye nims indienne ça ça dépend le du
ninja indienne c'est à dire c'est le nom
de ninkovic fameux joueur danois du 20e
siècle
mon système un grand grand livre sur les
échecs et une nouvelle conception
moderne
alors j'ai trois donc ici j'ai trois on
veut mettre le foin g2 et donc on va
jouer sur cette grande diagonale et bien
cette ouverture là avec des quatre c4
est comme ça j'ai trois là ça assez
c'est là dès l'ouverture catalan 1 voilà
on l'appelle sa couverture catalan un
des cinq est donc fier d'eux à noter la
valeur que les blancs monts ne craignent
pas la prise en c4 ont tout d'abord le
fou tu as pleuré sur la grande diagonale
mais ce pion de toute façon peut le
récupérer éventuellement si on veut tout
de suite en jouant damas quatre échecs
suivi de dame prend en c4 mais on se
regroupe sans doute joué aussi des coûts
plus plus lent le récupérer plus tard
comme c'est souvent le cas dans ce type
de d'ouverture du pion d'amis échec donc
ici un petit échec et après le coup
logique food et de on aurait pu tenter
aussi qualifié 3 mais pourquoi pas fou
des deux bon là on propose un échange de
fou regarde et on revient alors on se
demande pourquoi les noirs n'ont pas
joué tout de suite fouet cette faut le
savoir ça pourquoi les noirs n'ont pas
joué tout de suite fou aux sept puisque
la en jouant d'abord foot bk depuis il
faut aux sept îles ont donné un coup de
plus au blanc qui est le fou en d2 alors
l'idée est la suivante c'est que les
noirs considère que le fou en d2 et plus
mal placé finalement qu'en c1 voilà
alors c'est délicat si discutable mais
en fait on peut comprendre l'idée c'est
que si les noirs prennent plus tard ici
en c4 bien le pion des quatre attaques
et alors que quand le foot en ciel c'est
pas le cas et ce fou par ailleurs n'a
pas de très bonnes cases que ce soit en
c3 ou ailleurs il va plutôt aller en
effet quatre ans j'ai celle dont de
toute façon il serait y serait mal placé
voilà c'est pour ça que les noirs ne
n'eût pas de faire d'abord l'échec et de
revenir en donnant un temps de plus aux
blancs puisque ce temps est considéré
comme mauvais temps quoi carrière 3 à
noter que le cavaly maintenant protège
le pion des quatre donc on empêche les
noirs d'attaqué des quatre en cas de
prise ici petit rock petit rock pas de
problème car les 17 tout ça est logique
à noter un des problèmes du côté noir
ici c'est pour l'instant c'est un peu ce
fou qui pour l'instant débute sur le
pion russie s'il est un peu enfermé et
bombay il va falloir essayer plutard de
lui trouver un développement et la
méthode mc2 noter que les blancs retarde
le développement de leurs cavaliers en
jeu dame c2b il protège ses quatre
directement ils ont un petit oeil ici en
c2 bien sûr sur la case 4 parce que plus
tard avec alice et trois peut-être on
peut jouer qu'à des choses comme ça on a
envie de casser le pion des scènes
puisque ça libérerait la puissance du
fou et en faire jouer en n1 ces deux on
approche de la future liaison détour il
n'y a plus que le cavaly bien sortir et
les tours seront enfin lier le
développement pour être considérées
comme complètement achevé ses 6 alors
ces six très solide vis-à-vis de d5
on est d'accord puisque ça surprotège
mais ça rend encore plus problématique
la sortie du fou s'est vite puisque tous
les pions sur blanc maintenant
avant on pouvait envisager peut-être de
le mettre en c6 par exemple voilà c'est
fini
donc là pour l'instant il va rester
ensuite à priori un bon moment ou alors
on va jouer donc b6 fou bessette mais il
va taper sur ses propres pions bon ceci
dit
c'est ça c'est pas durer éternellement
puisqu'il y aura des prises d'eau tard
au centre alors tourné voilà on retarde
encore un sortie de ce cavalier garde le
contrôle sur ces quatre et on met la
tour en d1 avec un vis-à-vis toujours
pareil tour dames classique on aime bien
mettre une tour comme ça pourtant c'est
loin devant la dame adverse à la fin
d'une série descharles bay à la dame qui
est à attaquer et ça peut être un temps
précieux à la b6 voilà logique on l'a
dit b6 maintenant ce fou peut sortir
leur soit en b cette fois peut-être même
en a6 et a6 il ferait une petite
pression sur c4 arrive aussi qu'on joue
de cette façon là faut être quatre
maintenant on les blancs leurs frites en
d2b en veillant f4 on contrôle la casse
de 500 est récent mais sûr mais aussi
des cas notamment la casse ces sept là
en cas des changes en d5 ici belle
option celle ci sera attaqué faudrait
reprendre du pillon et puis fous ces 7
et la dame est embêté un dj d'aller en 1
ce qui est pas forcément agréable voilà
en tout cas c'est un fou qui est mieux
placé très certainement à f4 qu'en d2
voilà et notamment des deux baies on
peut envisager avec les blocs de sortir
ce cavalier b1 en d2 lui-même maintenant
que faut bouger et ça peut aider à la
poussée de 4 et pourquoi on veut pousser
au cas tour pareil pour faire des
échanges au centre qui vont libérer le
potentiel du fou j'ai 2 bon ceci dit
c'est vrai que ça libérera aussi
potentiel de fou s'est vite parce que ça
enlève ça enlèvera des pions qui le
qu'il empêche de bouger alors x 6 voilà
donc les noirs choisissons que le coup
plus active x 6 plutôt cool bessette est
un peu plus passif
voici ce match pose une question
attention je menace de prendre le pion
c4 alors prison des cinq plaisanté 5
alors attention peut pas reprendre ce
qu'on veut puisque la le pion c'est
cissé est attaqué bon ceci dit il ya
aussi le pion eux deux qui attaque et un
sorcier on prend ces six avec la dame
sur u2 est attaqué mais bon faut quand
même calculé tout ça et les noirs sont
bons
après calcul décide de prendre du plomb
c'est pourquoi pas on pouvait peut-être
prendre un des cinq autrement mais bon
ce option celle ci serait un tout petit
peu faible quand même puisque il serait
arriérés sous la menace du pion des
quatre qui l'empêcherait de bouger ans
et 5 mois c'est sans doute le coup
logique de prendre du plomb c'est sans
trop se poser de questions
maintenant cabello 5 alors câblés ou
cinq on met un cavalier au centre du
moment qu'il est protégé par le four en
cas de prison peut reprendre du fou sans
casser la structure de pions et puis bah
ce fou et tout de suite un tout petit
peu plus actif mais bon ils butent un
peu là pour l'instant sur des cinq pour
ça que les on aurait envie plus tard de
jouer au 4 mai c'est pas l'heure et puis
il faudrait que ce qu'avaient ils
sortent un jour ou l'autre
pour l'instant il attend son tour pour
ces huit attaques la dame et cavalli c6
alors ça c'était l'idée derrière
cavaillon 5 fourchette ou simili
fourchette entre la dame et le fou
puisqu'en fait bon c'est pas bon il faut
que j'aime est à noter qu'en prix en cas
de prise du fou quand la dame va jouer
là où on marque on a remarqué qu'elle
n'est pas obligée de jouer absolument
sauf qu'on peut pas bouger le fou le fou
n'a pas de case en fait voilà mais
l'idée c'est qu'évidemment latour
reprenait un abcès de mai le fou n'a pas
de casse donc indécis les prix en c5 ils
bloqueraient l'action de la tour dans ce
que je peux prendre la dame et madame
n'est pas attaqué et on b 4-1 b4y les
emprises mais je ne vais pas prendre le
fou puisque la dame est attaqué mais je
vais simplement si afu b4g simplement
qu'est ce que je vais faire simplement
tient à y avait quatre cents euros je
peux jouer à 3 à 3 à tacle attaque le
foot
voilà la dame adverse reste attaqué et
il est noir des problèmes voilà et là
l'idée donc ici c'est bon on va le voir
tout de suite c'est que bon mais maria
mesut où joue simplement fou bessin
voilà elle craint pas bien sûr cavale et
prend dames puisque on va reprendre la
dame avec une tour extrêmement active
les deux pions b2 et au devant de gros
gros souci à se faire
non non on prend le fou deux sets et à
près d'un an prend rd on à la fameuse
paire de fou alors que les noirs ne
l'ont plus ils ont plus le fou de cases
noires c'était un bon fou pour les noirs
puisqu'ils contrôlaient les cases de
couleur opposée de cette structure de
pions la voyez ses pions contre le blanc
donc se fout de cases noires étaient
vraiment leur complémentaire idéal
donc là on se sépare de ce bon fou c'est
bien joué c'est bien joué
tout ça doit être quand même assez
connus au niveau technique et maintenant
c'est l'heure voilà car les c3 en bloc
sur la tour à noter que tu t'attaques
sur le fou directement n'y a pas d'
attaque puisque la dame est attaqué il
suffit de bouger la dame par contre et
l'action sur le fou devient devient
importante cavaliers h5 pose une
question va se fout f4 bien placé
puissant il est puissant et le cadre
mais alors le problème de ce type de fou
évidemment c'est qu'il n'a pas de casse
de retrait là s'il ya des positions où
on a on à la case h2 pour le fou mais là
ce n'est pas le cas donc il va devoir
quitter cette belle c'est déjà
intéressant puis qui sait la seule louis
contrôle casse du centre la case ou 5 et
une casse important que casser cette qui
empêche les noix par exemple de doubler
leur tour ou en tout cas qui rend la
chose plus difficile
donc voilà donc
on sort le fou de cette belle case faut
3 pas beaucoup d'autres cazin on
envisager food et de aussi c'est
possible en fait trois pas en garde sur
de la tour ou des deux c'est peut-être
bien aussi bon je sais et hop cavaliers
et 6 ans revient en fait c'était juste
un coup les noirs les mythes propose aux
blancs mais rejoint f4 je rejoue kvh
scène dont fait partie du lot moi ça me
va je fais nul avec les noirs je gagne
quelques parties avec les blancs et je
lai le championnat du monde ça c'est sûr
c'est la menace est donc à quatre
attaques le fou maintenant véritablement
avec le pion puisqu'avec le cavalier je
rappelle qu'il ya un vis-à-vis tournage
donc si dynamique c'est bien de la part
des blancs ici la poussée quatre
normales case active pour le four plutôt
que de le reculer
on incite les bleus à jouer b3 mais
trois qui chasse le fou certes le fou
partirait en a 6 mai le cavaly ces trois
des plus protégés par un pion donc qui
devient faible et on peut envisager en
cas de doublement des taux bas elle et
blanc auront de problèmes alors qu'on
n'a pas envie de bouger le pion b2 donc
voilà ce type de coups qui est un peu
provocateur on a dit chasse mois le fou
rejoint le pion mais c'est pas forcément
une bonne idée et à 5
voilà que moyens nous y trouve joue à
cinq qui est un bon coup ici il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'autres d'autres bons
coups puisque fouet
4 on va se reprendre qu'avait h5 avec
une répétition c'est pas très
intéressant à sun pourquoi pas donc on
va affaiblir un peu les le dalon va
activer la tour sur la colonne à on
laisse tomber la colonne c'est qui pour
l'instant bon mais verrouiller un peu
pareil noir mais on va jouer sur la
colonne à si on arrive à doubler les
tours sur la colonne à c'est une bonne
ça serait une bonne nouvelle pour les
bleus ont prise simplement pourquoi pas
peut paraître curieux parce que on
éloigne un pion du centre le pion b
contre burnley lé bon et on donne tout
de suite la colonne avec une attaque sur
a7
pourquoi pas
tout reprend attaque bien sûr le pion à
les blancs on et ont une petite
initiative ici et là hop dame b 4 ou
tout à fait intéressant d'un bep cap
puisque je laisse le pion à 7
mais je fais pression un petit peu sur
b2 je fais aussi attention menace fou b3
et ici donc fourchette enfilade dam tour
donc là ça perdrait la qualité de simple
on peut pas prendre le pion à 7 à cause
de foot détroit et en plus on met la
dame sur une plaque hollande mais voilà
donc c'est l'idée des noirs en prenant
avec le bc qu'on va créer une pression
sur colombes et donc on lâche le pion à
7 pour prendre le pion b2 alors après si
on a tous les pions du même côté et la
paire de fou est moins puissante
la paire de fous et plus puissante s'il
ya des pions des deux ailes parce que
s'il ya des pions que deux sur une aile
les cavaliers sont aussi forts que les
fous ce qu'ils ont pas de longs trajets
à faire ils peuvent contrôler tous
regardé ce cavalier f6 imaginons que les
pions à 7 et b2 saute ce qu'elle est si
ce contrôle à la fois des singles et h7
donc il arrive à contrôler les deux
extrémités de la chaîne de pions voilà
donc les fous n'ont pas de supériorité
ici alors que c'est pas le cas et sur
des points hauts éloignés sur les plus
éloignés on peut pas contrôler à la fois
l'extrémité ici l'autre alors comme fou
il peut lui il ya un flou bien placé et
au centre bien peu contrôlée il peut la
fenêtre défensive d'un côté et
offensives de l'autre voilà donc c'est
celle avantages des fous dans l'est dans
les cas où les pions sont éloignées ce
qui est parce qu il sera pas le cas si
ses pions donc disparaissent donc l'itie
pour des impressions sur sur a7 et et
voilà tout simplement le travail sur la
colonne c'est fini le fou c4 est
merveilleux puisque on pourra jamais le
chat c'est quasiment là c'est presque
impossible de chasser il faudrait que ce
seul cavalier alors fondé venu en b1 d2
c'est très long c'est possible mais
selon et en attendant bombay voilà en
tout cas on a le pion b2 qui attaque est
pas facile à défendre même quasiment
impossible ou alors un coup très passifs
comme cabaye ibm et ça marche pas sans
doute poussé four b3 je prends le
cavalier je prend b2 et voilà c'est fini
donc bien défendu de la part des noirs
tout reprend à cette voie là dans prend
b2 logique dans prend tout reprend
mêlant des courses ici bon il ya un
petit peu le pion et doit attaquer mais
il est déjà défendue par cavalier on
peut mettre le fond des fasse
éventuellement même le roi s'il faut
faire attention puisque on se bourre et
un petit peu froid mais c'est quand même
jouable
et à part ça bombay on a quand même
position où la symétrie a été rétablie
au sens où on regarder la chaîne de
pions ici fait face à la chaîne de pions
là il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
pions qui peut créer de rupture
facilement ici et donc les deux
cavaliers valent très certainement les
deux fous du fait que voilà les pions
sont sur la toux ceux liés sur la même
elle fut f3 consolide de deux normales
et ashes voilà tranquillou h6 on évite
définitivement le match du couloir parce
que si on veut qu'il ait cette tour
faudra tôt ou tard faire attention à ça
quand même
agissons sous le ménage c'est une petite
porte envisagée pour pourquoi pas de
jouer les scènes certaine à certains cas
mais je pense que c'est surtout à la
fois pour enlever la case g5 au faou et
pour donner une case on h4 bon les bleus
en tout cas empêche des velléités alors
g5 et une petite menace peut-être parce
qu'on pouvait menacer de juger quatre
ans est embêté sous si ce fou bouge bien
ses pions et 2 qui quittera qu'un donc
quand même faire un tout petit peu
attention h katia pas de problème voilà
maintenant tour ses huit tours s'est
vite attention petit oeil sur le câble
et c3 qui n'est pas défendu
donc si le fou bouge ici mais c'est pas
facile de savoir où il peut bouger
peut-être pourrait venir en d3 parce que
sur food et 3 et bien si on prend on
prendra un cavalier puis à des plans
doublé c'est pas bon et puis en d3 prix
pourrait et le veut le cas et bougies
lyon pourrait le mettre quatre éliminés
ce fou software 3 ça pourrait être une
idée
alors faut être quatre pour l'instant
c'est pas joué alors là l'idée peut-être
que si les noirs ici tente un coup comme
fou détroit qui pourrait sembler
intéressante tout simplement on peut
envisager cavaliers d1 qui attaquent la
tour et après on gagne de points donc
c'est pas une idée quand même qui est un
peu peu olé olé et qui ne marche pas
tout simplement
donc ici ou f4 les noirs choisissent le
coutour ces deux voies la logique au
syli voilà alors du coup on peut se
demander à quoi s'est retroussée 8
on peut se demander à quoi sert tout
s'est vite parce que si financé pour
attaquer le lecavalier par tour ces deux
on aurait pu faire tout de suite et on
va pas bien à quoi sert la tour s'est
vite parce que l aide pas à faire un
échec en c1 puisque le fouet 4 veille
donc on peut se poser la question de la
légitimité de ce coup ici donc toi trois
défensifs
moi je veux je veux bien à la limite de
l'est certes à quelques avanies mais pas
à pas facilement
là tu vas devoir jouer le fou mais le
fou n'a pas de case en fait voilà c'est
difficile de savoir où mettre le pouls
il a pas de calais donc c'est pas facile
d'aller attaquer alors h5
alors ça c'est un coup curieux
5 ici quand par un hashtag en tout cas
ça empêche g4 alors c'est peut-être
l'idée des blancs ça peut être une idée
des blancs c'est de juger quatre pour
menacer g5 et déstabiliser sky m6 en
visant ben tu vas ou parce que si
cavalli pas apprécié que les 17 qui n'a
plus n'est plus défendu donc un coup
comme tour à cette ultérieure pourra
attaquer une pièce voilà cette
possibilité et de d'essayer de s'activer
de forcer un peu la position donc là les
noirs verrouillait ici en jouant h5
bombay verrouillage ces quatre là ont
peu plus un peu plus rien faire un peut
pas jouer avec g4 c'est quasiment fini à
jamais un projet de la meilleure
position du roi rien à dire sur ce coup
c'est normal et rush cette voie là
pareil pour les noirs j'améliore la
position de mon roi aussi j'ai pas peur
de me mettre sur cases blanches parce
que j'ai le fou de cases blanches moi
même on voit pas comment ce fauve 3
pourra venir faire un échec sur cette
diagonale tout les cas sont contrôlés
ici par des pions cette case ici par le
fou c'est quasiment impossible donc qui
risquent rien achète il pourra peut-être
même aller en justice pour ces voix là
alors c'est l'or maintenant pour les
blancs de simplifier bon j'élimine une
tour a un qui est pas vraiment active
même si elle soutient la torah 3 mai qui
visaient à la défense donc j'élimine
cette source
active contre le fou ça va enlever de la
pression sur deux donc ça va libérer mes
pièces je vais pouvoir jouer mes pièces
de façon un peu plus libre sans me
préoccuper du pion à eux deux tours
prend fou prend voit la normale
et e5 leur simplifie bon c'est un coup
un tout petit peu tendu si on veut
puisque bombay ça va laisser un pion
isolé des cinq au noir mais bon après
puis on prend cavaliers prend il ya le
fouet f3 qui va être attaqué on risque
donné la fameuse paire de fouet bon
c'est et puis le pion de décade peut
pousser aussi attaqué le caresser 3 qui
est déstabilisée et ce pion on va sans
doute pouvoir s'échanger aussi
facilement donc c'est sans doute
calculer précisément ici qui on prend
cavale et prend c'est une une petite
mini combinaison de de simplification
voilà en finale alors que faire avec les
blancs ici bas le fou là déjà il y les
prix c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
empêcher les champs il n'y a pas de case
ici qu'ils aillent s'est coincé x 3
alors on aurait eu envie ici bien sûr
ici aussi de jouer ou g5 ou g5 ça paraît
très intéressant parce que food prices
double les pions et en plus je veux nas
le pion des 5 mai les noirs jour et dans
ce cas là très certainement vérifie
voilà six cavaliers pros f3 j'élimine
d'abord le fou qui attaquent des 5 et
après la reprise par exemple du pion ou
d'une valeureuse qu'on peut reprendre du
roi ce qu'on peut reprendre non après
qu'elle les prend pour reprendre votre
certainement aussi si on ne veut pas
casser la structure de pions on va
prendre du roi ici
hélas les noirs peuvent simplement jouer
un coup comme cavale et décède par
exemple ou caves et les g4 en menaçant
échec et on sait pas c'est pas trop si
c'est pas les noirs ici qui deviennent
actifs là il ya plus une histoire de
père de fou il ya des fous de couleur
opposée il ya bon le roi qui peut se
prendre un échec ici on peut jouer des
quatre qui attaque dont il semblerait
que ce soit les noirs qui est un peu
d'initiatives ici bon rien de mon ami
dangereux mais bon voilà
parce que c'est la peine donc voilà donc
ici après calais prend le joue plutôt
fou ou trois bons c'est solide ça contre
leucate des cats pardon et dès qu'on a
envie de mettre le front des quatre ça
protège le cavalier et puis on est
devant un pion donc pas facile à déloger
ce fou qui ont plus pour s échanger
abscisses et puis ça empêche des cadres
voilà donc c'est sans doute un bon coup
très certainement aussi donc on élimine
le fou l'a choisi de prendre non pas du
roi
mais si du roi vous pouvez prendre aussi
du pion bon c'est pas si c'est bien ça
donne un pion passé quand même noir
était en prenant du roi ça paraît plus
logique
on a aussi le pion eu ici qui contrôlent
l avancée du pion des donc voilier en
finale il faut être précis et rien
dangereux ici mais voulu se faire
attention car les os 4 4
papa on n'a pas peur puisque cavale et
prend puis on prend un échec le roi est
obligé de prendre n'y a pas d'autres
coups intéressants et dans ce cas là je
prends eu deux trois pions contre trois
pions fou de couleurs opposées même s'il
reste les tours là bon là on sait que ça
c'est quasiment impossible à gagner sauf
grosse gaffe pas si impossible alors qu
à l epr ans puis on prend ra prend et
maintenant faut prendre 2 alors pour la
forme à pas en ayant encore quelques
coups mais là on sait déjà que la la
c'est fini là il ya vraiment plus rien
déjà depuis longtemps n'y a plus rien
fait avec les pions de même côté on
simple pour le spectacle qu'elle joue on
a l'impression ici tour à cinq attaques
le pion aux hcl mais pas vraiment
puisque le fou attaque 1 le fou défend
m6 m6 je mets les pions ici qui reste
sur la couleur du four parce que du coup
ben c'est le pion g7 qui tient la
position et on voit pas que le fou
pourra jamais attaqué g7 il n'a pas de
case pour attaquer g7 et que la tour qui
pourrait attaquer donc du coup ça c'est
on peut pas passer ça passable pour ses
cinq tours prend et c'est fini voilà
puisque la foudre que leur opposer c'est
fini même pas de plus en avant c'est
vous savez qu'il faut de couleurs
opposées même des fois avec 2 puis en
avance parfois même trois on n'arrive
pas à gagner donc hélas c'est même pas
la question
donc là on s'arrête ici avec une partie
nulle la proposait donc par l'ifa nous
puisque c'est le cas je vous ai dernier
coup ils ont accepté par madame ausy
toubon alors donc c'est bien pour le
pour maria qui a fait une quand même une
belle partie elle a été dynamique alors
il sait surprendre avec des 4 donc elle
est passée pas aller bien revenue dix
ans après sa défaite
de la partie précédente bon elle avait
des blancs quand même mais bon il va
falloir que pour pour le match qui a
laissé de gagner brand elle a essayé là
on peut pas dire qu'elle n'a pas essayé
et elle a fait une partie plutôt
intéressante dynamique donc c'est bien
pour le match maintenant reste à voir
comment elle va faire la partie numéro 4
avec où elle aura donc les noirs même si
elle prend une deuxième défaite on peut
dire que le mark snow match sera presque
plié parce qu'il a que dix parties est
donc ça va être très très dur donc il
faut qu'il faut qu'elle arrive à tenir
avec les noms la prochaine partie est
bon mais ça va être délicat parce qu'il
va falloir va falloir qu'elle choisisse
est-ce qu'elle va rejouer la même
variante parce que oui les fans va sans
doute aller la chercher sur la même
variante est ce qu'elle va jouer la même
chose ou sortir de sa préparation aller
chercher autre chose mais dans ce cas là
le prends des risques
voilà donc ça une partie intéressante la
quatrième pour savoir comment maria
voulzy tout va essayer de réagir à dans
ce championnat du monde pour essayer de
tenir le match et de ne pas se faire
écraser
trop trop rapidement est vrai mais
tenter de bien sûr de revenir voilà
merci de m'avoir suivi pour cette
troisième partie du championnat du monde
féminin 2016 sur des modèles tv
et puis vous pouvez allez donc sur le
site des gones al tv de canal tv pawn
comme nous demande souvent où sont
certaines vidéos des modèles tv elles ne
sont pas toutes disponibles ou même
endroit et donc si vous allez sur le
site diagonale tv.com et vous avez les
sources différentes pour pour trouver
l'ensemble des plus de 500 ou 600 vidéos
de fonelle tv il y en a quand même
beaucoup que vous pouvez consulter voilà
merci de m'avoir suivi à bientôt pour la
quatrième partie de ce championnat du
monde féminin 2016 au revoir